بصلاحيات قتال جديده وميزانيه عسكريه
مضاعفه تفتح اليابان وصفحه جديده في تاريخ
قواتها العسكريه
فبعد التعديل الذي اقرته الحكومه على ما
تعرف بالوثائق الثلاث
للاستراتيجيه الامنيه والدفاعيه اصبحت هذه
القوات تمتلك لاول مره منذ الحرب العالميه
الثانيه
صلاحيه شان هجمات ضد دوله معاديه
لكن الرئيس
يشدد على ان مثل تلك الضربات المضاده
ستختصره على الدفاع عن النفس ولم تكون
السباقيه ابدا
كوريا الشماليه صاروخا باليستيا مره فوق
اليابان وسقطت صواريخها في المنطقه
الاقتصاديه خالص لبلدنا هي تحضر لتجربه
نوويه تدفعون تلك التهديدات الواقعيه
لاجراء تعديل تاريخيا على سياساتنا
الدفاعيه
وفي ظل التعديلات الدفاعيه الجديده سيتم
مضاعفه الانفاق العسكري خلال السنوات
الخمس القادمه
المرتبه الثالثه بين اكبر الميزانيات
العسكريه بعد الولايات المتحده والصين
والتي اصبحت وفقا للتعديلات الجديده
التحدي الاستراتيجيه الاكبر لليابان ام
روسيا فهي تمثل الى جانب كوريا الشماليه
تحديدا محتمالا
قلق اليابان فقد اثبت ان وقوع مثل هذا
الغزو امر ممكن وعلى اليابان ان تتحضر لاي
سيناريو ومحتمل من خلال تعزيز قوتها
العسكريه وقدرتها على الرد
استراتيجيه الدفاع الجديده ايضا على تعزيز
قوه خفر السواحل لحمايه الجزر اليابانيه
النائيه في اشاره الى جزر تسميها اليابان
سين كاكو وتتنازعوا على السياده عليها مع
الصين ستراسل اليابان في العام القادم
مجموعه السبع و ستحصل على مقعد غير دائم
في مجلس الامن الدولي وهو من شانه ان يصلي
الاضواء على السياسات الخارجيه لليابان في
ظل قوانين الدفاعها الجديده فادي سلامه
الجزيره طوكيو